they're anything gross in plain sight
how much judging can you do with me in
this angle this is not a sponsored video
hi why I bought this at Zara why hello
I'm in my kitchen let's make things it's
summertime and you know what summer
means discovering those crevasses you
never knew your skin hat and obstacles
those are the only two things summer is
about don't let anyone tell you
otherwise everyone's to make a popsicle
on Pinterest YouTube etc I want to be
part of it oh I'm gonna make some
popsicles but I'm making grace helbig
style popsicles so they're gonna be slop
suppose for some unknown reason I truly
don't know why I've decided to make
breakfast popsicles because that's what
everyone craves first thing in the
morning unconditional love and popsicles
using breakfast items those are the only
two things that people crave in the
morning don't let anyone tell you
otherwise I have a variety of breakfast
food items that I assume human eat and I
have six ice Popp mold
ice pops is actually a nickname for my
dad because I'm a frigid [ __ ] popsicle
is not necessarily an individual type of
food it is more or less a method or
consuming food I've never made popsicles
before so I'm just going to guess how to
do it doesn't seem that difficult seems
like you just kind of get a thing of
moistness and then you just stick it in
this is how you do love oh wow I have to
buy sticks
no I didn't haha I will never learn
personal responsibility with this type
of product on the market hahaha this can
be used to make popsicles it can also be
used to create babies in in a pinch so
here are some other fun titles for these
popsicles a hard morning good or stiff
morning would you like a popsicle so
what's a common item that people eat for
breakfast their feelings yes that is
correct but Target didn't have that
cereal is the answer looking for cereal
I'm going to try and make six different
so slop circles are say milk and cereal
I have Lucky Charms actually I just have
the gross part of Lucky Charms because
like a responsible adult I ate all of
the marshmallows out of it
games just freeze right like what things
just freeze unless it's vodka that's the
only scientific experiment I've ever
truly paid attention to as an adult 11
o'clock at night so I'm gonna make all
these popsicles tonight and then we're
gonna pick this up tomorrow morning and
try all of them we'll put some milk in
now so some cereal in yeah I got a drink
some of the milk I felt it too much so
far so good oh my god Lipsky con it
that's the sign of a good old-fashioned
slop sack all these obstacles are really
great for when you're in a rush in the
morning and you're like oh my god I
didn't I do every responsible thing I
was supposed to do instead I made these
things pop suppose for six hours last
night so I put the lid on and now I put
this in and it does it click in should
read the instructions ah felt great our
first lobster Cole in the swamp what's
another thing people eat for breakfast
not their feelings
Cheska forget it it's quirky Joe good
job when I'm Ventris to Google I went on
Pinterest to Google search Eleni ol
dyslexia I went on Pinterest to search
popsicles just to get some inspiration
and the first photo I saw were these
yogurt blueberry vanilla popsicles and I
did welcome back did you take proud of
you
yogurt and fruit is something people eat
for breakfast so let's do it
oh they heated up blueberries in the
fall camp I don't remember exactly how
the recipe went I think it was like
blueberries and maple syrup but I have
honey so we're gonna do some blueberries
and honey can you do this King button on
each straining okay you're supposed to
get all the juices out Oh me Mom whoa
hey buddy you seen this enough look cows
or spray and now I got let those cool
for a second be cool meanwhile I think
we're supposed to mix some water and
yogurt or something got a bowl
special oh I just drank that bowl I'm so
strong physically and emotionally yeah
so I choked on nothing my words I
literally I can
idiot express anger subside water no
mixing the yogurt and the water
alternate some blueberries and yogurt so
let's put some yogurt in first okay now
put your blueberries in the rest of the
yogurt in there couple more blueberries
alright are you over and blueberry one
is done wow that's gorgeous
into the slop trough what's not having
people eat for breakfast not Jessica
sort of got a smoothie this is probably
the closest thing to a classic popsicle
that we're gonna get in this moment so
old gross bananas your novel or gross
you are okay Wow Wow this is attractive
the strawberries I should have got them
that's what the gang member who always
plays it safe said okay I gotta cut the
tops off of this and let's put some
honey and some milk great what magic ah
there's our fruit smoothie popsicle into
the slop trough what else do people for
breakfast Jessica I swear some people
are really bad at eating breakfast in
the morning and they only do coffee so
let's do a coffee popsicle I got some
Stumptown cold brew coffee which is the
town over from one of my favorite
locales dump town nope home brews there
no lingers hot steaming hot coffee into
our popsicle thing but we're also going
to put some creamer into that and I have
Girl Scout Thin Mint creamer hold your
dogs up ooh that looks like coffee but
wait what do you usually have
stereotypically with coffee Donuts we're
gonna throw some donut chunks in there
that's cool you can make any way oh it
looks like this was not the right choice
Wow they're titanic king quick ha
alright or pops pills in our slop trough
so far that's another thing people eat
for breakfast are you this type of
person a pretentious bottle of green
juice that actually I have probably more
sugar in it than the donuts let's see 27
grams
sugar is in this green juice or one
donut there's nine grams of sugars also
55 grams of carbs in this green juice
and quanti grams of carbs
in a doughnut let's just make a green
juice one and see what happens oh look
that looks like you're making right
choices alright and now we have one more
what's the last thing that you have for
breakfast Jessica this is your moment
that's right feeling so the last one is
going to be feeling because I didn't
figure out ingredients to make a thick
popsicle so yeah Wow and there we have
it we have all six of our flops achill
are morning goods now I put them in the
freezer night room in my freezer room
any ice cream in here and just like that
effortlessly put the popsicles in the
freezer and now we wait till morning
oh I show morning entrance it's okay I
just missed plans I know we've been
practicing good morning it is morning
time it's time to taste these popsicles
oh you feel dense and cold just like I
like my men I can tell you right now
feeling that feels about right just used
to run these on their hot water to
loosen them up so that they slide out
easily insert whatever sort of sexual
joke oh great there's a very long red
hair on these where did this red hair
come from Henry none of these are vegan
okay let's run them under warm water
well try the blue
our yogurt one first because I can
clearly identify the sponge okay aha
Thanks
it tastes like yogurt did it
this one's really good let's try some
more let's show what is just one okay
this one is cereal and milk Oh
someone has arrived I feel me I'm
tasting popsicles I tasted this one okay
see if you can figure out what that is
careful careful come home I can't watch
a grown man eaten I'm trying to get like
the flavor yeah and again there's
blueberry but yeah what I don't that
this is me oh these are all breakfast
theme you know tastes like what tastes
like that cream that comes with the
ptosis rules it's vanilla yogurt well
that's why I'm saying that's close to
what that is I think Swiss blueberries
and vanilla yogurt okay now I'm gonna
try this one this one I know what it is
I think you guys know what it is very
tasty mmm that's pretty good there's
stuff at the bottom no peanut butter
no you're just basing it on color
blending that's messing on a mine see
what you purchase you just had this at
nighttime
Fran what chocolate Brandon in Raisin
Bran no in that same realm cocoa bran
cereal syrup its lucky charms
Oh which one is this you can loosen them
up to get out of the face
nah yeah do they go to work work go
ahead taste that one chocolate Anna
reduce that one chocolate banana did you
make a chocolate no but at close yeah
pudding so smoothie it's strawberries
and bananas strawberries now now that
was a brown we go mmm best friend normal
okay
then I'm I'm saying about car a half I
taste the bottom part see if you can see
what else is in there
Oh coffees in there yes but there's
something else in there with the coffee
mmm everyone Boyd good doughnut oh
that's what you put hat when you just
grab like ground up those arms let's
chop them up and put it in the grass
number what about this one why don't you
make six no one's feeling Oh peas nope
it's our it's our there's nothing there
something you eat for breakfast yeah
another work it's a super juice a super
go I should know I saw you bottles
motion I know you saw all of the
ingredients is actually pretty good it's
just work way more sour when all the
rests are really sweet what time was
your favorite do you remember yes which
I'm feeling as a trap
there are your rings coming popsicles
your hard morning good I hope you guys
enjoyed this video don't forget
subscribe this channel and subscribe
just to see channel you've put enough
content now every Tuesday kind of do you
guys on the internet I don't know don't
popsicles are really good
yeah grace I agree the big